hallo ich heiße mai ich bin chemikerin
und ich mache es eines videos immer
werde ich gefragt wie kamst du auf
chemie warum interessierst du dich für
naturwissenschaft was ist daran so
faszinierend ja wo fange ich dann
vielleicht mit der sonne diesem riesigen
gas ball in dem winzige atomkerne
fusionieren was so verdammt heftig ist
dass selbst hier in fast 150 millionen
kilometern entfernung wir uns immer noch
in der wärme regeln können oder mit der
luft in jedem kubikmeter luft sausen 27
kva trillionen gasmoleküle her die mit
geschwindigkeiten von über 1000 km h
gegen deine haut prasseln die ganze zeit
[Musik]
was ist mit wasser ein geradezu
magisches molekül ein molekül das so
kleines dass es auf diesem planeten gar
nicht flüssig sein dürfte und doch
fließt es in unseren meeren und flüssen
und adam und zellen einfach nur wegen
eines kleinen knicks im molekül und
einer ungleichen elektronendichte
beteilung sein körper
der chemie labor es gibt kein atemzug
einen augenblick in dem keine chemischen
reaktionen in die ablaufen und dieses
video kannst du auch nur sehen wobei
gerade erlebt rom magnetische strahlen
von proteinen auf deiner netzhaut
absorbiert werden und du kannst mich
gerade nur hören weil schallwellen die
duftmoleküle um sich herum hin und
herschieben jeder noch so banale aspekt
dieses lebens wird interessant wenn man
die natur wissenschaftlich betrachtet
stein berge berge sind riesige riesige
haufen von ionen von geladenen teilchen
diese massiven steinwände werden durch
elektrostatische anziehung
zusammengehalten
warum also naturwissenschaften
gegenfrage wie kann man sich nicht für
naturwissenschaften interessieren sind
die nicht zu verbittern faszinierend bin
ich die einzige die der so sieht wenn
ihr das ähnlich sieht teil dieses video
sprit zum science lab und schreibt in
die kommentare was euch so fasziniert
[Musik]